I'm trying to pace myself consciously
because I know if I don't think about it
I will inhale this so today we're in
Koreatown Los Angeles we are at cockpit
bora we're gonna try some purple tree or
i means purple
yeah it's a purple cafe literally what
could be purple that's food because it's
sweet potato I love sweet potato I love
sweet potato too but I didn't know it is
purple no it's like orange there's
different ones clearly we know a lot
about this subject this is the prettiest
food
I think I'll ever consume it's just so
fancy I feel really cool oh there's some
more purple stuff in here I think this
is the extra extra stars like I always
get up late I'm so crazy messed way
that's crazy
it's funny because I never thought of
sweet potato as a flavor for shaved ice
and it works so perfectly like you can
taste the sweet potato definitely the
star of the show it's really light but
the flavor is very apparent and it's
really soft and in Bloods together
really well it tastes healthy I think
it's healthy
when I say it's healthy it might be
healthy by your standards
[Music]
so pretty look at this so soft again so
excited it's like a food porn like it's
a deep taste very deep it's like full of
flavors the first thing you taste is
definitely the sweet potato and then you
kind of taste like a cream yeah flavor
right it's definitely the perfect
soft-serve texture it feels fairly
simple and like it's flavors but that's
what makes it really really good the way
when you spoon it it just goes in like
that that's crazy that's a soft scoop
there you know it sounds weird but
there's something arousing about it you
said moist last time its moist
I got that on camera oh it's very soft
yeah
[Music]
super creamy oh yeah yeah
Oh Danks definitely a different flavor
than is your average Cheers
yeah actually that's not her I think
less intended less sugary the soup
potato is a little bit less pronounced I
think then the other two things that we
had this is almost like vanilla it's
like a few layers of different flavors
just like the creamy layer and then
you've got like kind of the more sweet
potato layer and then at the very bottom
is like a yellow cake okay sweet potato
as predicted it definitely came through
aesthetically but also the flavor was
warranted like it wasn't just purple
things to be purple like you could
really tell the reason it was purple was
because if it was sweet you know very
very aesthetic this is probably the most
aesthetic desserts I've ever had
everything's a fresh teak for him here
it was a surprise there's very different
than anything I've ever tasted but super
good signing off
[Music]